welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spider-man no way home's
upcoming digital and blu-ray release has
given us a ton of bonus footage already
of wholesome peter on peter on peter joy
from their re-staging of the meme to
lots of ass talk in the suits but but if
you pay close enough attention to these
interviews tom and toby actually drop a
little nugget that should stop our
hearts more than tom cameoine on
euphoria that tick tock was fake he
couldn't have been at lexi's play
because he was too busy saving fesco and
ashtray god i hope so now the moment i
am referring to was part of the
post-photo shoot interview with toby tom
and andrew take a look from a
choreography standpoint it's interesting
because spider-man's never fought with
spider-man before and i think what we
want to try and explore is an element of
us trying to figure each other out and
figure out our each individual unique
styles of how to be spider-man he is
chopping it a bit oh my god
i just can't and it's been killing me
because of the whole secrecy thing
because i want to go around and go like
hey wait you get on wires
i'm open for anything i'm ready to go
and that's about it to be honest with
you what did toby even say there hey
wait on wires clearly this interview was
done in the middle of production when
all three actors were still under a very
strict nda about speaking to press about
the film but it's the context that led
to this odd response that i'm more
curious about because tom holland was
answering a question about the
choreography of spider-man fighting with
another spider-man and sure we did see
some of that and no way home the whole
final battle shows the three peters
completely failing to communicate and
fully out of sync with each other
leading to an argument and then a
triumphant swing where they finally get
on the same rhythm my question is is
that something tom holland andrew
garfield and toby maguire had to figure
out the choreography of as actors like
the acrobatics of this moment are a
delight to watch but it's more of a
testament to great direction
storyboarding vfx stunts wire work
editing and music compared to true
acting through fight choreography as we
saw in cases like tony liang versus
simulu and chongqi and the reason i am
praying here is that as much as i truly
love noah holm's three peter scenes i've
always felt like something might have
been missing like something might have
been removed that odd quick draw moment
between toby maguire and andrew garfield
peter in ned's nana's living room what
was that all about and then the super
creepy way the two peters are first
framed in the moonlight when our peter
first sees them and then how suddenly
smooth that conversation goes right
after whenever superhero worlds collide
in the genre there's always a get to
know you fight the avengers in the woods
the rumble in civil war the guardians
pouncing on tony peter and strange
infinity war sweep into the legs and
into the spider verse doesn't it seem
like there was gonna be a bit more of a
peter versus peter versus peter in this
movie and now when tom holland talks
about spider-man fighting with
spider-man did he mean with another
spider-man or with another spider-man
well after spider-man no way home again
i realized there actually was one
perfect spot in this movie that may have
been in a previous version of this film
for a brutal spider-man vs spider-man
fight to go down one that would have
involved more complex fight choreography
that showcased each individual
incarnation of peter parker perhaps a
deleted scene that i would love to see
in these special features that are
ironically being promoted by these three
brothers hugging it out you know really
to see these details you just gotta
pause capture one frame of this moment
to better appreciate the details to stop
and smell the roses and wouldn't it be
great if you could just do this in your
life capture a single moment to remember
everything about where you were in that
second well imagine you could take a
picture to remember a special moment in
your life by getting a personalized star
map showing the unique alignment of the
stars at the exact time and place of
that special moment something you can
get thanks to today's sponsor under
lucky stars under lucky stars lets you
buy a beautiful print of a map of the
sky showing you the constellations and
locations of all the stars that were
right above your head during your
special moment you can choose from over
15 designs add a special commemoration
message title and pick the size the star
maps are printed on museum quality art
paper and you can get an additional
frame from one of their six beautiful
options they have a proprietary method
of locating the stars verified by nasa
astrophysicists to ensure that accuracy
so check out mine so i commemorated the
day our head of post-production riley
started work at new rock stars so
anytime he's more than 10 seconds late
to respond to my emails i can just look
up at the wall and remember a time
before he worked here i'm just kidding
riley i love you i mean obviously i do i
got this friend instead of my engagement
or my fiance's birth no photos of family
or loved ones on my walls just riley and
the fine folk said under lucky stars are
committed to keeping our skies clear and
free of space litter so they support and
fundraise for the international dark sky
association this makes a great personal
gift and a memorable gift and they're
giving our viewers an exclusive 10
discount so just go to
underluckystars.com
new rockstars and use the code new
rockstars to get your loved one a unique
gift now in the months before no way
home's release tom holland promised in
interviews that the hand-to-hand fight
choreography would be a lot more
visceral and that he needed to really
focus on his prep work because when
fighting characters from other
dimensions quote it really gets
complicated now sure he could have been
referring to his brutal fights with
willem dafoe as green goblin but i don't
really see how fighting green goblin in
this movie would be any different from
fighting any of the superpowered foes he
fought from his own dimension like when
he fought vulture or mysterio or thanos
or call obsidian or cap or falcon or
bucky or why in that october interview
tom would hold himself back from talking
about fighting green goblin someone we
all knew he was going to fight in this
movie it sounds like the careful thought
that this actor had to put into the
fight choreography with alternate
universe characters that he didn't want
to spoil in october was a fight planned
to go down between him and his other two
peters whose combat styles and their
films were indeed stylistically
different than his own i think there was
something more to the three peters
meeting each other in the second half of
this film like when i first saw that odd
little quick draw moment between andrew
and toby i thought oh cool that's how
these two peters react when they first
see each other wait till they run into a
peter at his lowest point what is he
gonna do when he sees them which led to
this interesting detail i discovered in
the no way home screenplay coming up on
page 127 when mj and ned brought the
other two peters to console our peter on
the roof of their school the same
direction reads remyverse and webb vs
peter stare down from the school's tower
silhouetted by the moon peter takes a
protective stance guarding his friends
as raimi verse and web verse peter swing
down and then peter says hey wait wait
whoa now in this movie's final cut which
this screenplay was rewritten for
rewards consideration to best reflect
this tense moment jumps straight to
peter nonverbally seeing himself in his
variants followed by their conversation
about grief but before that conversation
right after he sees this terrifying
image on the tower tom holland does this
tense inhale like a broken boxer
stealing himself before a final round
unafraid of the ko now this whole scene
this emotional beat as great as it
becomes once everyone starts talking did
seem just a hair rushed like the state
peter was in i don't know if he would
have kept his cool this well in his mind
he let his aunt die he had to flee and
leave her body behind and then j jonah
jameson rubbed salt in that wound we
never got to see this peter physically
lash out until the guy snapped and
wailed away at green goblin during the
final battle so given this dramatic
intimidating moon silhouette shot
peter's protective stance and the
undelivered upon promise of the other
two peters jumping a conflict i would
not be surprised if by spider-man
fighting with another spider-man tom was
really referring to an extended version
of this additional meeting in which
peter lost his [ __ ] and fought these
other two peters before these more
seasoned peter parkers overwhelmed him
using fighting moves they learned from
their unique experiences and held peter
down let him cry it out the way only
brothers know how to do i think this
kind of moment is what would have
preceded andrew garfield peter saying i
always wanted brothers and that tense
stared down between toby and tom when
tom wanted to impale green goblin with a
glider their non-verbal exchange here
was heartbreaking and there just seems
to be room here for this to be a
callback to a past moment between these
two an older brother restraining a
younger brother as has happened
countless times before now saying i had
your back before and i have it now you
can trust me bro it's not worth it those
are the kind of brothers who later call
each other out for wearing ass padding
and i'm not going to tell you who
but one of us has a fake ass in their
suit really
you can figure out that for yourself hey
yeah we need to get on wires be honest
did you want to see these peters in more
of an internal fight before they team up
in the final battle comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos follow me
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you'd love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you